Tình đứng a bà miếm mốt thống người, ít nhất 5 người đã thích mạo vì bảo mê li ra.
Cơn bảo này, nằm trong giòn bà cơn bảo mặt nhất từng đủ bộ bà vùng kerry bê tàn phản nặng này ra
mà ca, hay ti và cu ba trước khi suy yếu thẳng át thắc nhật đối,
ra mặt ca giải miệch chính, thế mạc, hơn 4 trạc xong mới gình hộ vẫn rất điet và hàng loạt công trình công cộng bị phảo huy hoàn toàn.
Tại hai ti, mưa lớn kéo dài khiến ít nhất 3 mốt người chết và 2 mười mất thích trong đó riêng thị trần P-Ti của bê có 2 mề bán người thịt mạo của 1 mề chế em.
Chuyên quyền cạnh bảo của mình có đùng phát dịch tả giòn nước nhật bình.
Cú bà nơi mê li ra đổ bộ với sự giòn các bà không vì nhận thương vong nhưng thịt hạ lưỡn với nhật cửa nông nghiệp và giòn thông.
Cô quan sự bảo át của weather ước tính, tổng thịt hạ kinh tế, giòn bảo mê li ra gây ra có thể lên tởi năm 2019.
Bí đô, biến tôn bảo này thành cơm bảo dưỡn giội thứ 3 từ nước gây nhận tại Caribeh.
Chúng chính là thực thây dưỡn mô tả tình hình tại ra mấy gà là tham phốc trong khi các chuyên giả khi hông cạnh bảo,
biến đô khi hộ và tình chạp lại dương âm lên, đăng khiến các cơn bảo hạnh hình thành gây tạm nhăn và tạm phát.
Cúc liệt hơn.